[SOFT MUSIC PLAYING]
PRAKASH SUBRAMANIAN: Brandfolder
lets brands collaborate,
distribute, store, and
manage digital assets
within our platform.
BRETT NEKOLNY: DevOps'
velocity at Brandfolder
has evolved over the last
year in quite a big way.
We brought operations in-house.
And our goal was to
really empower our teams
to enact positive
change, not having
a single group responsible
for gating that change,
but allowing our teams
to innovate on their own
with the support and guidance
of a centralized platform team,
but knowing that as we adopt
more Cloud native practices,
we'll continue to be able to
scale both teams and platform.
PRAKASH SUBRAMANIAN: One of the
biggest things for Brandfolder
as a digital asset
management company,
we wanted to get all the
digital assets into our system
as quickly as we
can so that we can
process them, and make it
available for our customers
for end use.
That was one of the
challenges that we ran into.
Sometimes, it would
take us a few minutes.
Sometimes, it would be
within a few microseconds
before an asset becomes
searchable within Brandfolder.
BRETT NEKOLNY: Little things,
like creating a sandbox
environment, where they can go
click around the Google Cloud
UI.
But knowing that once
they hit dev stage prod,
they're doing it all
through infrastructure
as code in Terraform.
Those are things that are making
our environment approachable
to the whole team, but also
setting standards in quality
such that we have consistent
employment across all
of those environments that are
higher than that of a sandbox.
PRAKASH SUBRAMANIAN: We wanted
to provide a healthy landscape
for teams to innovate and
experiment and try out
a few things.
The one thing that was really
surprising and exciting
was how our teams quickly
adapted and came up
to speed on new
technologies, and we
were able to impact
change to our customers.
BRETT NEKOLNY: The relationship
we have with the Google Cloud
team, especially throughout this
project, has been fantastic.
So we got a Slack
channel set up.
We've got pretty
consistent communication.
We set up weekly
meetings, knowing
how high profile
all of this work was
and how significant
of a change it
was for our operational
environment.
Within two weeks of go
live on all of this stuff,
the team reacting to
something that they
saw in such a Cloud
native way, in such a
we're in new
technology, we're going
to embrace that technology
way, and just really getting
into the details,
using their expertise
to solve problems that we
couldn't have prepped them for.
It's just awesome seeing
the teams respond that way,
learn that way, grow,
and embrace all of it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]